when you  got into trouble did you plan the way  back  exactly as it happened no no i got  [ __ ] lucky as [ __ ]  that my british counterpart ksi called  me out for a boxing match people joke  they say you know ks i saved your career  right because he called me out the box  and it gave me an opportunity to  literally  start my potential redemption by  fighting  my way back yeah to say um you know case  i saved your career  and in a way he did dude and then years  later i was able to bring him an  opportunity called prime hydration and  we'll see what happens but i want to say  one day in case i saved my career but i  made him a billionaire  is that why you reconciled with him  because i know you guys were beefing and  it felt kind of real case i and i  [ __ ] hated each other beef was real  then um i learned that like ksi and i  are like like [ __ ] the beef we're like  the same person across the pond  during prime [ __ ]